MALE SPEAKER: We're here in
Austin, Texas, where teams
have gathered from all over the
world to test their skills
of conquering a custom-built
obstacle course using nothing
but a LEGO Mindstorms
kit and an Android
powered phone or tablet.
Live from the Google Developers'
House at South by
Southwest, this is the
Google Developers
LEGO Mindstorms Rumble.
TYLER HANSON: Let's get
ready to rumble!
Are there enough geeks
in the house?
Give it up for the geeks
who have been playing
with LEGOs all day.
All right.
Do I have all of our teams?
Ladies and gentlemen, we are
live on the interweb.
I don't know who's
watching this.
Hi, people.
So what we've got going on here
is that these guys have
all been building furiously
since-- well, some team was
here at 10:00 in the morning--
making all these LEGO bots and
putting all that stuff.
We have an obstacle course that
these guys are going to
go through, a round robin.
Now, the rules.
You guys want to know
what the rules are?
They're very simple.
Rule number one, you don't
tell anybody that you did
this, since it's secret.
Right over here where I'm
standing, this is the starting
line, imaginary starting line.
There's a couple ladies here who
are going to drop flags,
and it's a very imaginary
course.
So the first rule right here,
you see this black tape?
This line on this side you
cannot have your bot on the
other side of it.
Does that make sense?
You're not allowed
to have your bot.
You can do whatever you can and
can figure any way to sit,
this is your box and
this is your box.
Now the driver.
Each team gets one driver.
You can't do any more.
I guess four people could
handle a tablet at once,
probably not.
You can have your pit
crew on your sides.
Now one driver, one driver, pit
crew The challenge is that
you've got to get from here
all the way over to there.
Now, you have to get all the way
into the box in order for
you to be equal.
Now, if they're hanging
over at all, then
that's not a win, right?
Now, what if you got these big
guys that are going to stick
out no matter what?
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
TYLER HANSON: What about
in there, though?
They got to park it?
They got to park it sideways.
So get your parallel parking
mind inside.
Now, the other rule, I'm
just going to keep
moving through here.
The other rule is that if your
bot flips over, i.e.
A turtle, you have
to start over.
OK, now your teammate
can help you pass
your bot back to here.
Or it gets stuck.
OK, so stuck or flipped over,
quicksand or turtle.
We can come up with
other euphemisms.
Now, what else are we missing?
So that's basically it.
That's pretty much it.
Now OK, does everybody know
what you're going
to be judged on?
First and foremost, we're going
to be judging on style.
Now I have an expert secret
panel of judges who I'm going
to reveal to you, who are going
to take notes and look
at all of this wonderful flair
that these guys have taken on
to give a little study.
And then I'm also going to go
through and actually talk to
each team and get
your guys' name.
Now, do I have all of our
teams in here now?
Has everybody had a drink?
Ah, there we go.
Very nice.
You can see by its design
that it was late.
We have 13 bots total.
Are we missing one then?
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
TYLER HANSON: It's
OK, he tried.
Now we also have Trevor Jones.
Hi, Trevor.
TREVOR JOHNS: Hi, Tyler.
TYLER HANSON: Trevor's coming
from the magical world of--
what state are you in?
TREVOR JOHNS: I'm pretty sure
I'm in Texas still.
TYLER HANSON: What state
of mind are you in?
TREVOR JOHNS: A very
different one.
So I'm coming to do you live
from our broadcast studio here
in the corner of the
Google South by
Southwest Developer House.
So yes, these teams have been
battling blood, sweat, and
tears to and bring us
their bots today.
They've been here since 10:00 AM
in the morning hacking both
on their Mindstorm kits and
their Android tablets.
It's looking like it's going to
be an exciting competition
and lots of fun.
TYLER HANSON: This is some
people's South By experience,
absolutely amazing.
Trevor is going to be giving us
technical analysis from the
amazing wonders of Studios One,
Two, Three, and Four.
We have a crash studio, we have
a lab studio, we have a
ground zero studio,
amongst others.
Who's playing music?
We're going to start
with you, then.
How are you?
DAVID: Good, how are you?
TYLER HANSON: Ah, David.
David, what is the name
of your team?
DAVID: We're with Ology, and our
robot is Eye of the Tiger.
It's an ode to Stallone.
TYLER HANSON: This is Eye of
the Tiger, it's an ode to
Stallone bot.
LEGO.
OK, where are you guys
all coming from?
Florida?
DAVID: Orlando, Florida.
TYLER HANSON: Orlando,
Florida.
Very, very unique city
in America, right?
It's like the Vatican
but different?
DAVID: Very different.
TYLER HANSON: Disney owns it.
Who's here?
MALE SPEAKER: Us.
TYLER HANSON: Hey, us.
What do you guys got?
Step over here.
MALE SPEAKER: We're Buckeye
LEGO Bot from Ohio.
TYLER HANSON: All the way from
Ohio, Buckeye LEGO bot.
And [INAUDIBLE]
you guys?
All you guys are from Ohio?
OK, did you guys have fun?
Was this worth your
day at South By?
OK.
Well, my friend, welcome,
welcome.
Please, come over here.
I like this one right here.
Oh my God.
That looks like Star Wars.
OK my friends, where
are you from?
MALE SPEAKER: We're from
Nantes in France.
TYLER HANSON: Nantes from
France, but not from--
no, that doesn't work.
These guys were here the first.
These guys got here at
10:00 in the morning.
And look at the amazing
wonderful [INAUDIBLE]
they invented.
And why did you guys decide
to do LEGO--?
MALE SPEAKER: We like this.
TYLER HANSON: You like robots?
MALE SPEAKER: Yeah.
TYLER HANSON: Well, you guys
have done a wonderful job.
I wish you really good luck.
That's from the bottom
of my heart.
My friend, which one is yours?
MATT: This is me.
TYLER HANSON: What
is your name?
MATT: My name's Matt.
The Curious Creature.
TYLER HANSON: Curious
Creature.
Ladies and gentlemen, we have
a very curious creature.
Matt, where are you
coming from?
MATT: Australia.
TYLER HANSON: All the way from
Australia, but you don't have
a very thick accent.
MATT: You know, g'day mate.
TYLER HANSON: No, no.
Don't do that.
Geek Dad, I know this guy.
All right, what do you got?
TYLER HANSON: We got
the Geek Droid.
The Geek Droid, and I see
that it sees in 3D?
MALE SPEAKER: Oh
yes, 3D vision.
TYLER HANSON: We have 3D vision
on here, and we have a
little [INAUDIBLE].
This guy drives everything.
And this is his branding
right here.
We got Geek Dad and Geek
Mom in the house.
It's a family affair.
We're very proud of you,
proud parents.
Do you have parents--
do you have children?
MALE SPEAKER: We do
have parents, yes.
TYLER HANSON: And children?
MALE SPEAKER: Yes.
TYLER HANSON: OK, who
am I missing?
Who's there?
Who's trying to brand
with Google?
MALE SPEAKER: Google Earth.
TYLER HANSON: OK, what
do you got here?
MALE SPEAKER: This is Team I Fix
It, we're streaming live
on youstream.com/ifixit straight
from the floor.
TYLER HANSON: Wow.
How many people are
watching that?
MALE SPEAKER: One!
And testing.
Oh, there it is, he's
got one signal.
TYLER HANSON: I Fix It,
that's you guys.
OK, judges take note.
Is this you?
This is you.
You are awesome.
What's your team name?
MALE SPEAKER: We are Punching
Muffins and the Unlimited
Sandwiches.
TYLER HANSON: OK one more
time, real slow.
MALE SPEAKER: Punching Muffins
and the Unlimited Sandwiches.
TYLER HANSON: Punching Muffins
Where are you guys from?
MALE SPEAKER: New Jersey.
TYLER HANSON: That makes
a lot of sense.
I love Jersey.
What part, Trenton?
Who am I missing?
Way over there.
Who's this?
That's you.
Step right in over here.
OK, who's going to speak?
CAMERON: This is Cameron.
TYLER HANSON: Hi, Cameron.
JOHN: John.
TYLER HANSON: Hi, John.
CAMERON: We are from Santa
Barbara, California.
TYLER HANSON: Whoo,
Santa Barbara.
I hear Oprah hangs out there.
CAMERON: She lives there.
TYLER HANSON: It's awesome.
OK, what's the name of
your guys' team?
CAMERON: Pelagonians.
TYLER HANSON: Pelagonians.
You guys are definitely
from the beach.
CAMERON: Yes.
TYLER HANSON: The flare--
CAMERON: This is WALL-E--
TYLER HANSON: This is WALL-E--
CAMERON: --bringing his
offering to EVE.
TYLER HANSON: Bringing his
offering to-- where's EVE?
Is she here?
CAMERON: You know what,
our [INAUDIBLE]
through.
She'll be here later.
TYLER HANSON: All right,
WALL-E, all the
way from Santa Barbara.
Unbelievable.
Where are you at?
Who's here?
MALE SPEAKER: Us.
TYLER HANSON: Us.
Hello, us.
How are you?
MALE SPEAKER: Very
good, thank you.
How are you?
TYLER HANSON: And you guys are
coming from a long way.
Are you guys from New
Jersey as well?
MALE SPEAKER: We're not.
We're from London, England.
TYLER HANSON: I've
heard of London.
Is that like--
it's a country?
Right.
What is the name of this guy?
MALE SPEAKER: He's called
Ralph by Southwest.
TYLER HANSON: Ralph by
Southwest. Fair enough.
And I see you did a great job
of doing another branding.
Is this kind of like the Street
View or different?
Fair enough.
What have we got here?
Whoa, whoa.
Come on over here,
stand right up.
What is your name?
ROB Z: I'm Rob Z, and my team
is Team Zed, or Team Z.
TYLER HANSON: Team Z, Team
Zed, and you look fierce.
ROB Z: I'm trying
to be fierce.
I'm leaning on fierce, I
understand it's a fierce
competition.
TYLER HANSON: There's a
fierce slash style.
So you can notice all this
technical stuff.
This is very nice, the decor,
the flames, it'll definitely
fly fast.
ROB Z: Thank you.
TYLER HANSON: Nice one, Rob.
My friend, how are you?
JAMAL: I'm fine, how are you.
TYLER HANSON: Not too bad.
Where are you coming from?
JAMAL: I'm coming from
San Antonio.
All the way from San Antonio.
And you've been here
a long time.
What is the name of your bot?
JAMAL: Cute Droid.
TYLER HANSON: Cute Droid.
What is your name?
JAMAL: [? Sinu Jamal. ?]
[?
TYLER HANSON: Sinu Jamal. ?]
Jamal, thank you so
much for playing.
He's been here forever
too, man.
You have a very technical bot.
And these blow up things?
Supposedly, maybe.
We'll see what happens.
Hey, we're almost there.
OK, where are we?
Who's left?
Who hasn't talked
about theirs?
FEMALE SPEAKER: Good question.
TYLER HANSON: Good question.
Who's here?
CHRIS: Team GB.
TYLER HANSON: [INAUDIBLE]
GB.
CHRIS: Team GB.
TYLER HANSON: Team GB, we
haven't done you, right?
Hello.
CHRIS: Hello.
I'm Chris, and this was called
WALL-E until they named theirs
WALL-E.
TYLER HANSON: Those bastards.
Wait, are you guys
both English?
Is this random that the
English guys decided?
You know, there's a joke
somewhere there in England.
If I was English, I would
be able to make fun.
But you could be EVE.
CHRIS: I don't know.
TYLER HANSON: You don't
have to be.
It's OK.
Maybe you guys could talk?
No, no, it's OK.
Somebody's going to have to
remind me all these names.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Good question,
Scott and David.
TYLER HANSON: Good question,
Scott and David?
No, they came in.
Where's Scott?
Where's David?
Oh, did they bail on us?
Come on.
Scott and David, paging
Scott and David.
How much time have we killed?
Trevor, you've had to look.
What do you think
of this madness?
TREVOR JOHNS: I think
it's quite the
selection of robots there.
I've got to say, my personal
favorite is the one with the
phone on it, even though it's
not an Android phone, I do
love that they're streaming
YouTube.
That's pretty cool.
TYLER HANSON: We're talking
about this one.
TREVOR JOHNS: Yeah, that's
the one right there.
TYLER HANSON: That feels
pretty good, right?
You see all that motion?
TREVOR JOHNS: We saw that one
there that posted online to
Twitter, right?
TYLER HANSON: There
was another one
that's doing Twitter?
Who's doing Twitter?
Oh, you didn't tell me
about your Twitter.
Where's your Twitter feed?
MALE SPEAKER: Well, we didn't
quite get it done.
TYLER HANSON: Oh, that's OK, but
it was a good intention.
TREVOR JOHNS: OK, they tried.
TYLER HANSON: Ah, the
free bar won I see.
All right, so now, my judges.
No, secret panel of
judges, exit.
We're going to give an
award for style, for
all your nice flair.
Do we need to have a pow wow?
MALE SPEAKER: Right now?
TYLER HANSON: Before
they get wrangled.
OK, I'm going to
kill some time.
You guys pow wow.
All right?
Do you guys need
another drink?
FEMALE SPEAKER: So they're going
to pick three finalists.
TYLER HANSON: OK
this is right.
So check it out.
We're going to pick three
finalists for the flair, and
then we're going to do
a crowd-sourced win.
Does that makes sense?
So these guys will decide who
the top three are, then I'll
let you, the audience,
and internet land.
Are you stealing LEGOs?
You can only win once.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Don't forget
about these down here.
TYLER HANSON: No, we
did those guys.
We're good.
OK, so what we need
to do now--
all right, listen to me.
Who wants to race?
We've seen the show, this
is like the auto show.
Now who wants to race?
Not at all.
We have to still
get this done?
Well, we pick the three.
They're still thinking.
What I'm thinking now is that we
can start putting them over
here on the tables, and then we
can start getting for our
actual race.
By the way, my name is Tyler
Hanson, and I like LEGOs.
Ah, so these guys have been
going like mad building all
these little robots, and the
amount of brain matter--
Trevor, how much brain matter
do you think we've used up
today inside the Developer
House?
TREVOR JOHNS: Honestly, I think
we've only actually used
a little bit, just because
there's so much here already.
We have an incredibly talented
group of developers.
Everybody here has been
doing an amazing job.
So many, so many
great designs.
So I think there's actually
been an incredibly large
amount of effort that's been put
into this, but there's so
many smart minds here too.
TYLER HANSON: The caloric brain
matter that's been used
up at South By is
unbelievable.
This is a very interactive
panel, as you can see.
Now what fascinates me is
all the people who are
watching us do this.
Now, if you're in internet land
and you're watching, why
are we doing this?
We're trying to explain that.
You guys have an idea?
You got your three?
OK, now can we just pocket that
thre come back to that at
the end, and then we'll do
a crowd-sourced win?
Or now?
Well, we don't really
have all the crowd.
Let's do it at the end.
So you guys go ahead and get me
those names written down.
You got the names?
Ladies and gentlemen, in case
you were wondering, we're
making all of this
up right now.
This is real, this is now.
This is not yesterday.
There was no spreadsheet
for this.
FEMALE SPEAKER: [INAUDIBLE].
TYLER HANSON: Which team?
MALE SPEAKER: Curious
creatures.
TYLER HANSON: Curious
Is that a go cam?
MALE SPEAKER: [INAUDIBLE].
TYLER HANSON: Not bad.
Does that thing skydive?
MALE SPEAKER: It can.
TYLER HANSON: OK, this one?
MALE SPEAKER: Yeah.
TYLER HANSON: Whose is this?
FEMALE SPEAKER: Nantesters.
TYLER HANSON: Nansters, all
the way from France.
Nice job.
The French have a
lot of style.
I don't know if you
guys knew that.
MALE SPEAKER: And WALL-E.
TYLER HANSON: And WALL-E, there
goes my awesomeness.
This WALL-E The Santa
Barbara WALL-E.
MALE SPEAKER: Pelagonians.
TYLER HANSON: Pelagonians,
Pelagonians.
And who's the first?
Who are we going
to start with?
Where's my board?
Ah, let me explain this.
OK, since it's a race, we
have to have a bracket.
Look at this officialness.
Now there wasn't a spreadsheet,
but there was a
DIY made bracket board.
We're going to start
right up here.
So Curious Creatures,
you guys are good.
You're going to stay
right there.
And do I have Rubix?
Rubix is gone.
Done.
So what we do?
We fill in?
[INAUDIBLE].
Aha.
Now we move them up to here.
Got it?
Geek Droid.
Curious Creatures.
You know, this is where
it gets technical.
Do me a favor, now, for on
that side here, if we can
let's go ahead and set our
little happy droids on that
table right over there.
Let me cross the stream.
Excuse me, sorry, excuse
me, sorry.
Let's get all the alcohol
out of here.
All right, clear the runway.
I don't know what's
more absurd.
MALE SPEAKER: We're going to
talk about how they were built
and stuff earlier today, OK?
So [INAUDIBLE] you're going
to see it here.
I want you to start by saying,
you know, earlier today, these
guys were building stuff, and
let's take a look at the
things [INAUDIBLE].
TREVOR JOHNS: So earlier in the
day, these teams have been
gathered at 10:00 AM to go and
put these bots together.
We gave each of them a LEGO
Mindstorms development kit, as
well an Android tablet, and told
them to basically come up
with the most creative
design they could.
So they started out just putting
together the sample
tutorial bot, the most basic
design, and they had no chance
of winning the competition if
they just stuck to the most
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
design, because our course is
filled with tons of obstacles.
And they might be small, but
these bots are small, too.
So it was their job to come up
with creative ways to go and
make sure they could overcome
all of these.
So whether or not it was levers
that pushed them over
it, unique wheel designs.
We also told them to go and
come up with creative
mechanical and software
solutions.
So they've been trying to go
and come up with the most
innovative ways to go and clear
this course as fast as
possible, as innovatively as
possible, and with the most
style and finesse.
TYLER HANSON: Style,
innovation, speed.
That's what we're
all about here,
in case you're wondering.
Now, do I have a flag girl?
Or a tissue?
TREVOR JOHNS: So I should also
point out the hardware
platform these folks
have been using to
remote control the robots.
So each team's been given an
Android tablet which has a
Bluetooth connection to the
LEGO Mindstorms NXT brick.
Each team can then use whatever
control software they
want to use.
We gave them a sample program.
But from there, it was up to
them how they wanted to go and
modify the UI, modify the
algorithms that control the
robot, what their strategy
was for going
and controlling these.
Each tablet, most of them are
using a touch screen where
they can go and either
individually operate each
motor, or just give forward,
backward, left, right
controls, and tell the
robots where to go.
From there, they'd have to
modify it if they added extra
controls, some of them modified
it to go and use
sound, add all these
options to the UI.
All of the software is open
source, so they just
downloaded it, opened it up,
modified it using the Android
SDK, and basically just went
and customized it to their
hearts' content.
So really, it was up to each
team's creativity to figure
out where they went
with all of this.
And they had a lot of options, a
lot of directions they could
go in, both using the power of
LEGO Mindstorms and the power
of the Android SDK to go and
remote control all of this.
Thank you so much, Trevor,
for explaining
exactly what we're doing.
Now, do we have somebody
who's got the time?
Hey, and it's illegal to control
somebody else's droid,
so stop doing that.
Don't even think about it.
Not allowed.
Do I have a timekeeper?
We're good.
I we missing?
Where are we at?
How do we feel about this live
performance, internet land?
All you wacky people out there
in internet world who don't
have anything better to
do than watch kids--
I mean grown-ups--
race LEGOs.
TYLER HANSON: What's that?
Ah, thank NewTek, who's
doing all of this.
You guys are amazing.
So we have some awesome people
who are doing the live stream
and helping out with
all of this.
NewTek, is it newtek.com,
is that right?
Out of San Antonio, and they
have this whole live streaming
TV studio in a box.
It's unbelievable.
I haven't seen anything
like this.
MALE SPEAKER: [INAUDIBLE].
TYLER HANSON: Oh my
god, it's there.
That's freaking-- no, no, no,
don't cross the streams!
TREVOR JOHNS: Not to mention,
they built this awesome studio
for me over here.
TYLER HANSON: Trevor,
did you feel that?
TREVOR JOHNS: I did, I did.
You know, you ought
to be careful.
You can't get that too close.
Who's know what will happen?
TYLER HANSON: That was like a
reverse deja vu, or something.
Is that a vuja de,
from France?
Very similar.
All right, enough silly.
Now, race, race, race.
OK, ladies and gentlemen.
Where' s my timekeeper here?
Oh yeah, we've got
to get technical.
He has to put his drink down.
Where's my flag lady?
Drop it and pick it up.
OK, watch her.
On your marks--
FEMALE SPEAKER: No!
TYLER HANSON: That
was a test run.
I'll do the on your marks.
On your marks, get set,
and go, and then
drop, and then drive.
OK, you guys got it?
Very simple.
On your marks, get set, go.
We have [INAUDIBLE]
giving out.
[INAUDIBLE] is looking good,
technical challenging, over
the [INAUDIBLE].
Whoa.
The droid [INAUDIBLE].
Oh, full monty, coming
all the way through.
Stuck here.
OK, you're not stuck yet.
Until you're stuck, then
you can switch.
That's good.
OK, mentally put your
mind into it.
Very nice technical driving.
Unbelievable, going through.
OK, Team Go Pro Camera
is having a hard
time finding its way.
Geek Dad navigating
the keyboard.
All right, give me five.
I've got five here on this guy.
OK, look.
Watch his--
[INAUDIBLE].
OK, wait for it.
No.
We would like to thank
our sponsor.
OK, there we go.
OK, very nice, very technical.
That was a swirlydoo,
that's a LEGO term.
You're looking good, OK.
Very nice, OK, you have
to come over.
It's very hard to watch both.
Oh, what's our time?
MALE SPEAKER: [INAUDIBLE].
TYLER HANSON: One
minute, 19.9.
Geek Dad.
Nice win.
Trevor, what did you think of
Geek Dad, that technical-- did
you see where they did
that [INAUDIBLE]
around the corner?
TREVOR JOHNS: Yes, so this was
an excellent example of how
even if you've got a good
design, driving skill is just
as important.
That being said, their design
certainly helped them as well.
They had a back-heavy robot
that allowed them to clear
right over those obstacles.
They didn't need to rely on any
mechanical action, they
just pushed right through it,
which gave them a speed
advantage as well.
I think both robots had a great
chance there, but in the
end, it just came down to
superior driving skills.
TYLER HANSON: You know, with a
name like Geek Dad, it's kind
of hard to compete.
Where's Geek Mom?
FEMALE SPEAKER: Right here.
TYLER HANSON: Yeah, nice
job, Geek Mom.
I'm very proud of you.
MALE SPEAKER: Trevor.
TYLER HANSON: If I had parents,
I might want you guys
as parents.
OK, Allogy?
Allegore?
Allogy?
Frame store, you guys
take lane one.
And then who are we missing?
MALE SPEAKER: It's on YouTube
forward slash developers.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
TYLER HANSON: Allegory?
Allogy?
A-L-L-O-G-Y?
Max?
TREVOR JOHNS: So we're also
pulling the video feed off of
the Go Pro on that
last robots.
We're going to see if we
get that to you live.
We'll have to see if we can read
it, but we're sending a
team over there right now to go
and try to extract the data
off the robot, and we'll let
you know how that goes.
TYLER HANSON: Which
teams was it?
Max and--
FEMALE SPEAKER: These are the
names of the people from their
teams.
TYLER HANSON: That
was a big one.
David?
Chris?
[INAUDIBLE]?
Max?
Anybody?
Where did they go?
They go to the bar?
MALE SPEAKER: Frame store.
TYLER HANSON: You
guys get it by?
Yes, you [INAUDIBLE].
OK, we're going to swap.
We'll move you forward.
This is how it works.
If you get drunk at the bar
and you're not racing, you
lose, just so you know.
I just made that rule up, too.
OK, we're going to go with
Nantes, Nantes from Nantes.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Pelagonians.
TYLER HANSON: And Pelagonians.
Pelagonians?
Yeah, you're good.
That's totally fine,
that's legit.
And Pelagonians.
How's the instant replay
coming along?
Have you seen a slow
motion cross into
the finish line yet?
TREVOR JOHNS: I haven't
seen it yet, no.
TYLER HANSON: OK, you
tell me when you do.
OK so now, you can see
who we got coming up.
We got all the way from Nantes,
France, which is an
amazing, creative, unbelievably
artistic town in
France, for all you people
who don't know.
And just wait until you see
how it moves, he tells me.
And then all the way from
Santa Barbara, we have--
what did you call yourselves?
MALE SPEAKER: Pelagonians.
TYLER HANSON: Pelagonians,
how could I forget?
It's like a Patagonian,
but a Pelagonian.
What's the opposite?
You guys made it up
on the fly, I like
that, really creative.
All right, we have
a flag dropper.
You always have to have a pretty
lady to drop the flag.
And we have a start?
OK, give me your thumbs
up when you're ready.
You guys feeling good?
Wait until you see
how it moves.
OK, silence on the set.
Pay attention everybody, this
is really serious business.
On your marks, get set, ride!
Oh yeah, that's good.
The Santa Barbara guys--
TREVOR JOHNS: Looks like a
little bit of technical
difficulty there at
the starting gate.
TYLER HANSON: Yeah, Trevor,
can you see
what they're doing?
TREVOR JOHNS: I can
see it from here.
I've got a monitor, I've
got nice display here.
TYLER HANSON: Show them--
what is that?
Trevor, what exactly are
they trying to do?
TREVOR JOHNS: So they're trying
to go and use those
extra large wheels with the arms
on them to try and clear
right over any obstacles
in the path.
Now the problem, though, is that
they're just not getting
the traction needed to go and
pull the robot forward.
So they're making a little
bit of headway.
Now, there should be motors that
are used to go and push
that robot forward, and I'm
not sure what's happening
here, so maybe they're having
some technical difficulties.
But [INAUDIBLE]
should be trying to push them
forward, so I'm not sure
what's happening there.
TYLER HANSON: Over here in Santa
Barbara, in Pelagonia's
land, we have a free-wheeling,
unbelievable technical skills.
It must be the head
and the leaf.
Is that the California
state flower?
OK, I was just making sure.
This is a PG-13 show.
Man, this machine is rolling.
Unbelievable.
Nantes, with all its artistic
creativity, this is why
socialism doesn't work.
I'm sorry, I didn't mean that.
Unbelievable technical
[INAUDIBLE].
So close!
Almost there.
You can get EVE!
You can do it!
Oh, take a droid out.
TREVOR JOHNS: Now you do get
some bonus points, at least as
far as style's concerned,
for extra destruction.
TYLER HANSON: Absolutely.
You're getting technical advance
from other people.
OK, unfortunately, you can't
really see, probably.
You're doing good.
Nantes, how are we looking?
The suspense is killing me.
Oh!
You're close.
TREVOR JOHNS: So the problem
is, [INAUDIBLE] wheels just
aren't able to clear [INAUDIBLE]
obstacle.
TYLER HANSON: You know, it
was that great flair
that they put on there.
You see how they put that
Terminator wheel thing on?
That's killing them.
We got a few technical skills
trying to come in.
You're so close, but
unfortunately, I don't think
you're going to be able to
get around that way.
OK, slide it, looking
at it, OK, good.
Holy cow, you guys got it,
the monster's coming.
This thing is going
to eat you up.
Never count out the French.
Come on, you can do this.
Unbelievable, the technical
skills.
MALE SPEAKER: Little
more left, Cameron.
TYLER HANSON: Little to
the left, he says.
Nantes, I love your creativity,
it's unbelievable.
You've got to parallel park.
Straight, shoot the gap.
Unbelievable!
Almost. You know, Nantes could
still win, because these guys
might get stuck.
Oh, no, Nantes might not win.
What do we do?
Unfortunately, this
is what happens.
You have to start over.
OK, pass the Holy [INAUDIBLE].
[CHANTS]
Because you got stuck.
If you get stuck,
it starts over.
All right.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
TYLER HANSON: I have no words.
France--
TREVOR JOHNS: Yes unfortunately,
without those
actuator arms in the front
that are going to push it
along, I just don't
see any way that
robot's going to recover.
TYLER HANSON: Yeah, you know,
it's a tragic situation here.
It's a tough day for France.
Buy those guys a round.
OK, five minutes.
There you go.
OK, this is a single race.
I want everybody to cheer in
their mind right now for this
little robot.
Don't clap, don't scream.
Unbelievable.
Now, these guys do have
a little bit of
AI, don't they, Trevor?
There's a little bit of AI in
there, and a little bit of a
mental relay system
that I think that
people can link up on.
So if you guys give this a
little hope in your mind.
Now, you don't have to scream
and yell because
they are deaf still.
LEGO's working on that,
their new 3.0
version of this Mindstorm.
I don't know what's more
ridiculous, me talking about
what this LEGO's doing or you
in internet land watching.
MALE SPEAKER: You've got to
go around this blue brick.
TYLER HANSON: It's
the blue brick.
It's always the blue brick.
OK, there you go.
TREVOR JOHNS: So this is
precisely what that second
robot was designed to go and
overcome with those long arms,
just push it right
over those walls.
But again, it was
just too heavy.
It wasn't able to go and propel
itself and push it
across the field.
And if you just can't
move, you're not
going to make any progress.
So even though this first robot
is having a little more
trouble getting over those
obstacles, it still has enough
speed and enough agility to go
and launch itself over it.
So it might not be the most
elegant solution, but they are
making progress in the race.
TYLER HANSON: Now they still
have to get this last part,
which they weren't able to do.
So I don't know, Trevor.
I have faith, but--
oh, no.
You're good.
You can still do this.
Oh, man.
MALE SPEAKER: WALL-E!
WALL-E!
TYLER HANSON: The natives
are getting restless.
And coming from behind,
Nantes, out the gate!
It reminds me something like
Aliens or something, like such
a unique design.
All right, I think it's
time to go get a
round of drinks, everybody.
What are we burning on?
MALE SPEAKER: Almost ten.
Two minutes.
TYLER HANSON: Don't worry, it's
only been seven minutes.
You might want to charge
your batteries.
I would like to thank
our sponsors.
MALE SPEAKER: Yeah!
TYLER HANSON: Unbelievable.
Over around the corner.
Of course, if you haven't
figured it out--
that's very nice, he just side
tracked all of that.
MALE SPEAKER: Slow and steady!
TYLER HANSON: Slow and steady,
you've got all the time in the
world, clearly.
OK, over the hurdle nice.
You're almost there,
you're home free.
[INAUDIBLE]
technical?
MALE SPEAKER: [INAUDIBLE].
TYLER HANSON: I don't know,
this could work.
This could work.
So close.
There isn't a lot of punch.
How many horsepowers
are in this thing?
TREVOR JOHNS: So we did
give each team three
motors to work with.
So in this case, they're just
using two to go and drive
those wheels forward and back.
If they'd used that third motor
to go and try and build
some sort of arm to go and vault
themself over their last
obstacle, they might have
had a little bit
more success here.
They still might make it, but
it's going to be a matter of
driving skill and not
technical ability.
TYLER HANSON: Yeah, it really
does come down to the
technical-- hey!
Nantes the--
oh, turtle.
Oh my God.
Are they pulling the plug?
So who wins, technically?
You guys are out, OK.
Unbelievable.
My god, in my 25 years of
telecasting live LEGO
[? races ?]
that's one of the most bizarre
races I've ever seen.
That one's for the
books, people.
France, unbelievable.
I'm going to say a joke, don't
get hurt, but you know
what a camel is?
It's a horse designed
by a committee.
You guys get best
design award.
I'm really proud of you.
You've been here all
day, unbelievable.
Thank you guys.
OK, Santa Barbara?
You guys might want
to charge your
batteries after that race.
I don't know if you'll
have enough.
So we have an instant replay.
Trevor, tell them
how they won.
TREVOR JOHNS: So I don't see
instant replay over here.
I hope maybe they can
launch it for me.
Oh, there we go.
Actually, I think we actually
have the video
from the Go Pro now.
So we're watching the video from
the last race, with the
robot in the back, and you can
see it slowly trying to make
its way back up to the front.
But just getting--
actually, we've changed
video again here.
But you can see how they were
able to almost make it.
They got blocked by that first
robot right out of the gate,
which put them at a
disadvantage, and they just
weren't able to get enough speed
to go and clear that
first obstacle.
Now, it would have been
interesting to see if they had
used the pulleys in the front,
the treads in the front, to
try and actually pull themselves
up the ramp, and
you can see them trying to do
it right there, but just not
getting the traction they need
to actually get over that
second obstacle, and that's
really where they got slowed
down too much and couldn't
win the race.
TYLER HANSON: That's absolutely
right, Trevor.
That's unbelievable.
I'm really excited about this
next team, we have I Fix It
and Team Z. I Fix It,
where are you at?
You're there.
Grab your little bot.
Ladies and gentlemen, in case
you're wondering, we're live
from Austin, Texas.
This is really, really,
really happening.
Are there actually people
inside watching on TV?
Oh my God.
Hello, people who are watching
TV. Unbelievable.
Are you guys having
a good time?
Yeah, it's a brilliant
TV show.
I've seen this somewhere.
Unbelievable.
All right, do we
have everybody?
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
TYLER HANSON: Ladies
and gentlemen, are
you still with us?
Are you still here?
Are you still at South by
Southwest and watching LEGOs?
My God, the stamina.
The race.
OK, so we have coming up,
looking very hot, Team Z, I
Fix It, live streaming
to themselves.
OK, you guys all
programmed up?
I love your guys' branding,
great job on the branding, and
great job on the flair.
OK, what are we missing?
What do you need?
Trevor, what do you think
of these guys?
TREVOR JOHNS: Well, like I said
earlier, I really love
the camera on there that's
giving us live streaming from
that one robot.
But as far as technical ability,
I think either one of
them could actually
make the race.
They're both pretty evenly
matched as far as I can tell.
Can we get a close-up
on those bots?
So the one on the left there, we
can see they have two large
wheels, a couple small
wheels in the back.
So the big thing for them is
trying to avoid tipping over
whenever they go over any
of those obstacles.
TYLER HANSON: A little
top heavy, yes.
TREVOR JOHNS: But I don't really
see anything to go and
keep their balance when they go
over them on the back, so
it'll be interesting to
see whether or not
they flip or not.
MALE SPEAKER: I Fix It
[INAUDIBLE] custom control
[INAUDIBLE].
TYLER HANSON: Now, the track
system is very interesting.
You guys went old school with
the military tank, it's almost
like a [? Sherman. ?]
TREVOR JOHNS: Those treads are
going to be really good at
getting over the obstacles if
they can get enough clearance
to get the obstacles
underneath them.
TYLER HANSON: Absolutely, it's
all about the chassis.
TREVOR JOHNS: So the really
interesting thing to see there
is whether or not they'll even
be able to get enough momentum
to get up and over.
Once they get part of the way
up, they should be clear the
rest of the way.
And in their case, too, they are
pretty top heavy, so it'll
be interesting to see whether
or not they can keep their
stability throughout the entire
race as well, too.
So I think we've got two really
good robots here.
Both stand a really
good chance.
I think that the extra weight
from that phone is going to
slow the treads down.
You're also going to see those
treads are a bit slower, too.
Usually when you have a wheel,
you can get a little bit more
momentum there.
And on top of that, you have
a little bit more room for
creativity as far as the drive
train's concerned.
TYLER HANSON: [INAUDIBLE]
let's do this.
All right, stopwatch,
pretty girl.
Ladies and gentlemen, are
you guys ready for this?
Start your batteries, on your
marks, pick one, pick two, go!
And they're coming
out of the gate.
Ah, with the tank move, look
at that moveability.
OK, Team Z, having tough problem
getting out of the
[UNINTELLIGIBLE].
Tank Man, coming all
the way through.
I fix anything, slowly.
Look at the patience
carrying through.
OK, you've got to navigate
this little wall.
Over the death field
of mouse, mouses--
oh, mice.
Whoa, going for the triple
whammy, that's an old World
War II trick.
Looking heavy.
Team Z, still trying to
get out of the gate.
Looking tough.
TREVOR JOHNS: So you'll notice
how even though the first
robot there is tough, they're
using that arm in the back to
keep themselves from
tipping over.
But on the front, they have the
same problem, and they've
got another wheel to go and keep
them steady there, too.
Now they're going to lose a
little bit of control when
those treads come
off the ground.
But once they drive forward, it
gives the robot a chance to
right itself and get that
stability back.
Now you'll also notice how those
treads are making the
robot go a little bit slower,
but the team's using it to an
advantage in this case.
They're using it to make sure
they have more control.
The second robot is definitely
faster, but it's running into
the walls, which
is [INAUDIBLE].
TYLER HANSON: Unbelievable
balance.
I think the phone on top is
actually given a great
counterbalance, it's like
a tightrope walker.
Back over here, we have
Team Z, who's
having a tough problem.
He's still trying to get over
the death cords of mice.
Slowly but surely,
I fix anything.
You've got a straight shot
there, it looks good.
Once you're past the pink
one, it's home free.
Unbelievable technical
abilities.
All right.
Technical skill, live streaming
abilities, and a
great pointing technique.
I don't know if you guys
see the pointing.
[INAUDIBLE] in record time.
MALE SPEAKER: One minute 50.
TYLER HANSON: One minute, 50
seconds, I Fix It, with the
tank and the [? iStream. ?]
Team Z?
You're still-- you know?
But it looks good doing it.
Trevor, it went to
them, the tank.
OK, let's move them along.
TREVOR JOHNS: This was
definitely a case of slow and
steady winning the race here.
TREVOR JOHNS: Even though the
second bot there was a lot
faster, the first one had just
a little bit more control,
which gave it the edge.
TYLER HANSON: All right,
good questions.
Coming up next, on
bat Who we got?
We got both of you?
You guys C?
We have good questions and
Punching Muffins and the
Unlimited Sandwiches.
Wait, so--
TREVOR JOHNS: So actually, we
have Kyle from I Fix It here
in the studio, who's going to
go ahead and give us a quick
rundown of what they did with
some custom control software
to make all this work.
So Kyle?
KYLE: So we took one of the
off the shelf, open source
Android apps, and modified it
to make the control more
consistent.
Because the initial apps
are just too jittery.
There's one based on
accelerometer, and it's not
consistent enough.
So we were able to download
the SDK and get it going.
Started about one o'clock, and
by six o'clock, we had a
custom app.
So if you're interested in I Fix
It, we have instructions
on how to fix any Android
device, including these guys.
Ifixit.com.
TYLER HANSON: Ifixit.com, coming
in with the big win.
OK, all you people out there
in magic internet land.
How about you people
in the bar?
You guys having a good time
watching the big screen TV?
You sound like a rowdy bunch.
Unbelievable.
In case you're wondering, you're
watching grown adults
play with LEGOs, and this is
South by Southwest, the most
innovative, creative
spot on the planet.
And who doesn't love LEGOs?
MALE SPEAKER: My team!
TYLER HANSON: You guys,
how are you looking?
Which one's which?
OK, Good Idea?
Good Question, that's
a good question.
Punching Muffins, the Unlimited
Sandwiches.
I can't do it enough here.
OK, Trev, what do you think
about these guys, real quick?
Side panel analysis.
TREVOR JOHNS: Hey,
sorry about that.
Yes, so we've got two robots
here who both have a similar
strategy, neither of which has
very much in the way of front
obstacle avoidance.
So the one in the front does
have that wheel, which is
going to go ahead and
make sure that it
doesn't fall forward.
It gives it a little bit
of a counterbalance.
The other one just
has a flat plane.
But in both cases, neither of
them look like they really
have much of a way
to go and push
themselves over obstacles.
So it's going to be just
pure speed here.
How fast can they go
ahead and launch
themselves over all of that?
TYLER HANSON: Excellent.
Ladies and gentlemen, are you
ready for another race?
From the bar.
I need to hear you
from the bar.
Are you guys still
drinking with me?
Unbelievable.
Do I have my clock?
Watch.
He's here.
Pretty lady?
You guys ready for this?
OK, uno, dos, tres!
Coming out of the back,
[INAUDIBLE].
Unbelievable [INAUDIBLE].
Good Question, looking tough.
You are awesome.
OK, looks for the ride.
Oh, sneaks in behind.
Oh, look at [INAUDIBLE]
Sandwich.
That's good, [INAUDIBLE].
Yeah go ahead, start
them over.
Punching Muffins and Unlimited
Sandwiches is doing amazingly.
Right around the corner, looking
at the wall of death.
This is the green monster,
coming from behind is a very
good question.
Oh, unbalancing.
Yes, no.
You've got to spin around.
OK, technically, we call
this a bottleneck.
This is when the bots
are making love.
They like each other.
Oh, that's called
a [INAUDIBLE].
I'm going to say this is the
female, that's the male.
OK, coming around the corner.
Yes, looking good.
OK, you got-- yes, all right.
Power bleep through
it, he says.
Trevor, what do you think about
this capability on the
green wall?
Oh, here we come.
Oh, man.
I don't know what to say.
TREVOR JOHNS: So in this case,
that robot is probably a
little bit too back heavy.
It's not able to get enough
traction on those front wheels
to go and get itself
up that ramp.
Now it might have some more
success if it actually tried
to get up it backwards, but
I'm not sure if that robot
will have enough control
to actually do that.
So it'll be interesting to see
what their strategy is to try
and get over this ramp.
TYLER HANSON: Yeah, I think
their strategy is praying.
They got a lot of pointing,
they've got a
little technical there?
OK, They went for the lean,
slim machine, but it looks
like you've really got
to have weight here.
TREVOR JOHNS: I also hear a
lot of clicking over here,
which means that they're
actually trying to put too
much torque on those motors.
These motors, they're only
good for a little bit of
thrust, and if you want to do
more, you actually have to go
and use a gear box, essentially,
to go and try and
get a little bit more
power out of those.
You're trading speed
for power.
Right now, they're trying all
for speed, and when you do
that, you just don't get enough
power to go and push
you up these inclines,
especially if
your robot's heavy.
TYLER HANSON: I think
they call it oomph.
Yeah, you just can't
get the oomph.
Oh!
The suspense is killing me!
Smart comment, coming up next.
Ladies and gentlemen, I'd
like to thank our
sponsors, the bar.
Oh, now they're mating.
What happens if neither one
can get over the wall?
I'll let them leave it there.
Absolutely not.
The crowdsourced rules.
All right, you know
there's rules in
this thing for a reason.
I don't want to have a
violent altercation.
Yeah that's right, back
where you started.
Do we have a time limit?
10 minutes is our time limit.
If you can't get over here in
five minutes, we're going to
have to put you in--
All right, you've got one
minute to get past this.
If you guys work together, you
might be able to do it.
Teamwork!
TREVOR JOHNS: Now their best
bet to get over this ramp
would have been just draw speed,
try and take a direct
shot right at that ramp and try
and get enough momentum to
push themselves over it.
But because of the pile of mice
right in front of it,
there really is no direct
approach to that ramp.
They're going to have to steer
around it, and they're going
to lose their speed and they're
going to lose their
power because of that.
TYLER HANSON: Yeah this hill, it
must be like in ant terms,
this is like a 5,000
foot incline.
30 seconds.
30 seconds if the two of you
can't get past this line,
whoever's the farthest wins.
Nine, eight, seven, six, five,
four, three, two, one.
It's still a win.
Unbelievable.
All right, Punching Muffins and
the Unbelievable Sandwich.
Unbelievable Sandwich.
That was not amazing.
Trevor?
TREVOR JOHNS: Yeah.
TYLER HANSON: I don't have
much to say, do you?
TREVOR JOHNS: Yeah, I think they
both had a chance if they
just could have gotten a little
bit more momentum or a
little bit more power,
either one.
And both robots were lacking
in both of those.
If that pile of mice wasn't
there, or they had just
designed their drive train a
little bit differently so they
could get that little bit
of oomph to go and get
them over that ramp.
It was close.
They both had a good chance.
TYLER HANSON: Awesome.
So now that's you guys,
that's Buckeye?
OK, Buckeye LEGO
bot and Team--
oh, Great Britain.
I get it!
All right, ladies
and gentlemen.
MALE SPEAKER: Follow us on
Twitter, BuckeyeLegoBot.
TYLER HANSON: BuckeyeLegoBot.
Come on, let's try and get
these guys one million
followers now.
You know what the street value
of that Twitter feed would be?
Get into technical position,
pit crews.
OK, Trevor, you want to
give a quick-- we got
another track in.
Trevor, have a look.
TREVOR JOHNS: So I just I got
a picture of this bot here.
Could you zoom in a little bit,
though, so I can see what
they're doing here?
OK, so actually, this is a
really interesting design.
I actually don't know what
to think of this.
It looks like they built some
sort of forklift on the front
that's going to go and try and
push them over the obstacles.
It'll be interesting to
see how this works.
It's definitely a
unique design.
I really don't know what
to make of this one.
It'll be interesting to
see it in the field.
TYLER HANSON: All right.
All the way from Great Britain,
we are replacing a
battery pack, technical
difficulties.
Pit crew?
TREVOR JOHNS: All right, and as
for the second robot here.
First off, I love how they're
going and being creative about
actually getting it to
fit in the box there.
It's definitely a
longer robot.
Now they've got that scoop on
the front, which is going to
go and try and push them
over the obstacles.
It doesn't look like it's
mechanical, so they're going
to need to rely on speed
there to go and try to
push them over it.
Now, they do have that wheel in
the back that you've se a
few times already, and that's
going to go and give them that
extra bit of stability.
So even though they're going
to go and intentionally try
and capsize the robot, it'll
hold them steady, allow them
to drive over it, and right
themselves back when they've
gotten to the other side.
So I think this design is
actually pretty solid.
It'll be interesting to see
whether or not to the extra
length is going to give them
enough clearance to navigate
the course.
I think they might have a little
bit of trouble when
they get to the end, trying
to navigate those last few
obstacles, just because of the
extra size, but I think this
robot stands an excellent
chance.
TYLER HANSON: I concur.
How close are we
on our battery?
Chris?
How close are we on the
battery change?
OK, we're good.
Coming all the way from
across the pond.
Come on, give it up.
This is tough work.
All right, ladies and gentlemen,
you ready to do
this again?
Unbelievable!
Clock?
Ready.
Beautiful lady?
Winner.
OK, you guys good?
GB?
OK, you checking your text?
It's OK.
[SPEAKING FOREIGN LANGUAGE]
And they're off!
Coming out!
Tank with its superpowers
is looking tough.
We had a mating.
This is cross-pollinating.
They are sharing data.
Oh, Team GB, looking tough,
falling on the other side.
Now, we're seeing a lot
of problems here.
The wall of death!
Oooh, almost!
[INAUDIBLE]
Oh, and the tank just doesn't
have enough weight.
You've going to have to
do a shimmy-shammy.
I don't know what you call
that in England, but in
America we call it the
shimmy-shammy.
OK, through the mines.
Coming out of the [INAUDIBLE].
You're still good, man,
you can cruise
right in upside down.
I don't care how you win.
Nobody said the British
were good looking.
The flippy floppy.
So Trevor, it seems that the
bots that are very condensed
and don't have a lot of whoopee
outside, do the best.
TREVOR JOHNS: Yeah, the smaller
bots definitely seem
to have bit of an advantage in
this course, just because the
clearance between everything
is so small.
Again, you also see how good
the design treads are.
TYLER HANSON: One minute!
TREVOR JOHNS: Even though the
bot was pretty much out, it
was able to get that last little
bit of control there
from those threads and keep
moving even though it
shouldn't have. And that first
bot, even though it looked
like it had a great chance to
go and win because of the
design to go and launch itself
over the obstacles, it gave it
a little bit more instability,
where the smaller bot just was
able to go and keep moving.
I also loved how they made use
of those three sticks in the
back, the extra poles.
So there were a few times when
it looked like the bot was
almost ready to go and flip
backwards, it kept itself
righted, and that was a very
simple design that proved to
be very effective.
TYLER HANSON: I totally
concur, Trevor.
Team GB, all the way from
Great Britain, nice job.
Buckeyes, better
luck next time.
OK, now we're missing.
Do we have an Allegy?
Allegory?
Team?
Are we missing a team?
We're forfeiting you,
moving you forward.
OK, Geek Droid?
Where's my Geek Dad at?
Geek Droid?
Geek Dad?
Geek Mom?
Where did they go?
What are they doing?
Messing with the
flux capacitor?
[INAUDIBLE].
There we go, look at
this, very nice.
Yeah, you're back on.
Add a team.
I just want you to know,
I have equal
support for both of you.
I care, I really do.
And the sooner that we can
get done with this.
Trevor, tell me what you see.
So now we have two
winners here.
One was a technical forfeit
winner, but it all counts.
A win's a win.
We have another team from
England, and we have Geek Dad
again, of course.
First up, we haven't seen the--
we have another track.
Trevor, let them have it.
TREVOR JOHNS: All right, let's
take a look at those robots
there, see what we've got.
Have we got a camera that
we can zoom in here?
All right.
So that first robot,
very simple design.
I love the sunglasses.
Again, you see the combination
of treads with the wheel for a
little bit of stability, in
this case in the front.
So it'll be interesting to see
whether or not they'll
actually be able to go and again
push themselves over
those obstacles.
Now, I think that wheel might
actually be on a motor there,
so they're actually going to be
able to lift it up and give
themselves a little
bit of a hop.
So in the case that the treads
aren't enough, it might push
them into position.
So that could be a winning
design right there.
All right, let's take a look
at the other robot.
All right, looks like another
larger design here.
Now, they do seem to have an
actuator arm in front.
And so again, they could
use that to go and push
themselves.
But I think in this case, the
bigger wheels are going to
give them enough on its own.
Now you will notice this team
put a second set of smaller
wheels inside, with the hopes
that if the larger wheels lose
contact, those smaller wheels
might keep them on the ground
and keep them moving.
So it'll be interesting to see
how well that works compared
to the other design, which is
going to more actively try and
push themself into position.
TYLER HANSON: Thank
you, Trevor.
Now, you've got to
reboot twice?
OK, we're doing a little
reboot, technical
difficulties.
I would like to thank our
sponsors, the bar, Google,
LEGO, Droid.
Really, we're brought to you
by Google Developers.
And so all those wacky things
that come to you are coming
from the minds of this.
This is how they learn.
This is technically actually
what Google's campus looks
like day in and day out.
You've heard stories, right?
OK, how are we looking?
Does anybody have
the boot sign?
What is the song?
[HUMS JEOPARDY THEME]
Well, all you people out there
in internet land, we'd like to
thank you for watching us.
I hope you have another thing
programmed for afterwards,
maybe a Netflix movie, maybe
I don't even know.
We have technical
difficulties.
I love the close-up cam.
Can we get a slow motion
replay of that?
We're loaded.
OK.
We have a watch, we have
a flag, we have
races, we're ready.
Eeny, meeny, miny, moe, catch
a tiger by the toe!
And they're off!
Coming out, Geek Dad looking
tough, coming
into a pile of mice.
Hopefully he doesn't get wrapped
up in the [INAUDIBLE].
TREVOR JOHNS: A lot of teams,
they have this decision right
off the bat whether or not
they're going to try and drive
around that pile of mice
or go right over it.
And it's definitely one of the
more challenging obstacles in
the course, just because of
that mass of cables there.
But on the other hand, you
do lose some speed by
going around it.
So in this case, going over it
was definitely the right
approach for this team.
And the other one,
they had treads.
They probably could
have gone over it.
So I'm curious to know why that
team decided that driving
around was the better
option there.
TYLER HANSON: They're
looking good.
They do have the weight.
But now look here.
Geek Dad, now he already
[INAUDIBLE] the first one, and
he does have the fastest course
already, so he knows
this track really well.
Unbelievable, this is the
closest race we've ever had.
Ladies and gentlemen, this could
come down to the wire.
TREVOR JOHNS: So it looks like
the wheel on that second robot
there occasionally
gets in the way.
It would probably be nice to see
if they can modify their
control software to give them a
little bit more flexibility,
so they can decide whether
or not it's up or down.
Whereas right now, it looks
like it's just on a cycle.
When they hit the button, it'll
cycle, give the robot a
bit of a hop, and keep going.
TYLER HANSON: Whoa!
Technicality, anybody?
I think we're OK.
Geek Dad, you won.
Geek Dad again, round two.
What's the time on that?
1:15.
Didn't beat your first round,
but you had the two fastest
qualifying times.
The track system.
Trevor, you want
to talk about--
this is the first track
system that we
didn't see win, actually.
TREVOR JOHNS: Like I said, I
think the robot with treads
had a pretty good chance, but
that wheel got in the way just
a couple times.
Also, their treads weren't
quite as powerful as they
could have been.
This is another case where it
would have been nice to see
them use a gearbox to try and
get a little bit more power.
I mean, they've already
lost a bit of speed
by going with treads.
They probably could have lost a
little bit more in exchange
for more clearing ability
on those obstacles.
Again, both great designs.
We've see both designs succeed
in this course.
But in this case, that little
extra bit of speed combined
with just a great physical
design to go and clear those
obstacles seemed to be a
winning combination.
TYLER HANSON: Oh my God.
Well, I've got to give
it up for you guys.
You did a hell of a race,
and it was a great time.
Geek Dad, all the
way to the top.
Ladies and gentlemen, we have
our next [INAUDIBLE].
Pelagonians?
Pelagonians, which
is different than
Patagonia, and I Fix It.
Where are you guys at?
MALE SPEAKER: Here.
TYLER HANSON: Yeah,
you're here.
TYLER HANSON: All right, where's
my Patagonians at?
All the way from
Santa Barbara.
Colson and Beau, what's up?
Colson and Beau, this is
to say hello to you.
So hi, guys.
I know you're watching
in Santa Barbara.
I just got paid to do that.
That was a paid endorsement.
All right.
We have two other winners here
now, bonafide winners.
I Fix It coming in strong,
all the way.
Are you guys still streaming?
You're from SLO?
And from Santa Barbara?
Oh my God, this is like
a real rivalry.
This is like bona fide rivals.
Oh my God.
Ladies and gentlemen, we have
just had an amazing California
convergence.
These people are actually
real rivals.
We have a Santa Barbara team
and a San Louis Obispo, aka
SLO, coming in.
Trevor, so we've see both
of these win now.
What do you think about the
state flower and WALL-E here?
TREVOR JOHNS: They're both
powerful designs.
We've seen them both
perform stunningly
throughout the last round.
So I'm honestly not sure
which is going to win.
Now, I do think those treads
combined with the extra
weight, which actually gives it
a little bit more ability
to go and pop over those
obstacles for the robot on the
left there might actually be an
advantage, but it could go
either way.
I have no idea which way this
race is going to go.
It's going to be exciting.
TYLER HANSON: All right ladies
and gentlemen, are we ready?
People, are you still with us?
Drivers?
Start your engines.
We now have a pretty fly guy.
Watch.
On your marks, get set, drive!
And they're coming
out the gate.
It's looking tough.
Now of course, Pelagonian had
a tough problem here with
their tough thing.
He's going to start
over right away.
Good move.
I Fix It, coming through.
Looking tough.
[INAUDIBLE] streaming all the
way from Austin, Texas.
We have another track system.
Looking tough.
Technical skills are
unbelievable here.
I don't know if you can notice
how diverse they are moving.
This is unbelievable.
Now with the weight, as we've
seen, we've seen a lot of
tracking not being able
to work here.
But because of the phone,
it weighs a lot,
so it actually helps.
These guys are actually
now helping more.
Pelagonians are coming
on inside.
OK, it's still uncertain.
Oh man, guys.
You should have swapped out.
Oh no.
Santa Barbara.
I don't know what
happened here.
You guys made it over
the course.
Have you been drinking?
Has the robot been drinking?
Pelagonians, coming
in [INAUDIBLE].
It's a very technical
challenging course, obviously.
We might have had a low battery
here with fuel warnings.
I don't know if they can do
a pit stop and swap out.
Start them over.
OK, so you got a ramp
over here, he says.
Pit crew?
For those of you who are still
paying attention to this,
without the phone, I don't think
you have enough weight.
But I lied.
There we go, tank.
OK, you've done this before,
Santa Barbara.
You know how to do this.
OK, watch your hands now,
watch your hands.
Even playing field, OK?
And remember this way is
opposite in TV land.
All right, you're
looking good.
OK, very technical aspect.
I Fix It coming on around.
Navigating, this is where
it gets easy, but
you've got a tough one!
Here comes [INAUDIBLE]!
Oh my god!
What could happen?
Beat down.
All right, you've got
it, you've got it!
You know how to do this.
You've got to get to
that gate before.
Oh my god, they're sweating.
The concentration
unbelievable.
Such a close race,
That's the closest
race we've had.
TREVOR JOHNS: I think either
of them easily
could have won there.
So I've got Stephen
[? Canvan ?]
with me here from LEGO.
This is the second year we've
been doing this, the first
year we've been live
streaming it.
So Stephen, tell me a little bit
about what it's like to be
back here, the atmosphere.
What do you think
of this event?
STEPHEN CANVAN: Right.
Well Trevor, last year, it was
cool and awesome, but this
time, we are really
lifting the bar.
This is the best event
at South By, really.
That's what we said last year,
but this time, it's even true.
TREVOR JOHNS: [INAUDIBLE]
true.
There's a lot of excitement
in the air.
I think I agree.
This is by far the best event.
TYLER HANSON: I'm sweating.
Punching Muffins and Team GB.
Where's my Great Britain
boys at?
Founding fathers?
Oh boy, they clearly
have been drinking.
They're going to break out into
soccer songs here soon.
All right, how are
we looking, guys?
Pick your course,
pick your lane.
OK, again, we have two different
styles, one with a
track system and one
with the wheels.
Now, Punching Muffins didn't
navigate fairly well,
and you fixed it.
And Team GB, coming in with
the old Sherman Tank.
Are you guys ready?
We're going to keep this
thing rolling.
Thumbs up?
Ready to go?
Start your engines.
On your marks, get set, ride!
TREVOR JOHNS: So two very, very
simple designs here, both
of them proven, both of them
much simpler than what we saw
in the last round.
So I think in this case, we're
going to see very similar
performance here from
both of them.
Really, though, it's going
to come down to
treads versus wheels.
My money's on treads, just
because of its ability to go
and clear obstacles so well.
The really interesting thing
will be to see whoever wins
this round pitted up against
the winners of next round.
So we'll see a very simple
design against a much more
elaborate design, and see
who comes out of this.
But in this case, really it's
just treads versus wheels and
see how that goes.
TYLER HANSON: All right,
[INAUDIBLE]
powering through.
I agree Trevor, whoever's going
to win this one is going
to go into the top qualifier.
GB's coming out of the gate.
Oh, does the same trick again!
Unbelievable!
I don't know what they call it
in Britain but in America, I
can't say that on TV.
TREVOR JOHNS: Exact same
obstacle that flipped them
over last time.
Unless that other bot's able
to clear in the next few
minutes, or the next few
moments, rather, I think we're
going to see another victory
for the treads.
TYLER HANSON: Yeah, the way that
they're going to navigate
this and come in in style,
clearly, Team Great Britain is
just too much for
the Americans.
Yes, you can do it.
Unbelievable!
For the Queen!
For the Queen.
One minute 30, unbelievable
time, boys.
Technical skills knocking
them out.
I Fix It and Geek Dad.
Yeah, you are.
I Fix It and Geek Dad, we are
down to the final three teams
for this competition.
I was just told that we now
have one million people
watching this on YouTube.
Unbelievable.
MALE SPEAKER: Only
one million?
TYLER HANSON: Only
one million.
We got batteries, we
got batteries.
Go, step into the pit stop.
MALE SPEAKER: John,
how are you?
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
TYLER HANSON: Absolutely.
Back at the studio, we are
rebuilding the whole studio
and thinking about
some things.
Ladies and gentlemen, for those
of you who are still
with us, I just want to say I'm
really proud that you are
still with us.
It takes a lot of stamina
to watch people--
let me rephrase that.
Grown adults watch grown
adults play with LEGOs.
You know, I don't know what you
guys wanted to be when I
grew up, but never did I think
that it would be a LEGO
telecaster.
I would like to thank our
sponsors, beer and alcohol.
But really, none of this could
happen without the great
wonders of the Danish minds
of LEGO and Google.
In case you're wondering,
YouTube is part of Google,
thus we have such great
placement on
the page right now.
Back in the day, I used to
have to pay for that.
Ladies and gentlemen, for those
of you who are just
getting here, this really
is a LEGO race.
This is all happening
right now.
This isn't a figment of
your imagination.
These are all individual,
unique snowflakes.
How's that battery
change coming?
TREVOR JOHNS: So we are using
rechargeable battery packs,
and we have a supply of them
for all the racers.
So in theory, these changes
should be pretty quick.
But the problem is, when you
go build your robot around
these control bricks, and the
battery's located underneath
the control brick.
So by the time your robot is
finished, you might not have
access to the battery pack
anymore, and that's what we're
seeing right here.
So they'll definitely get it in
a moment, but they do have
to partially take their robot
apart just to get to the
bottom of that control pack
and swap that battery out.
So I'm sure they'll be back in
action in just a moment here.
TYLER HANSON: All right, I Fix
It, how are we looking?
What do we got?
You feel solid?
OK, they're back!
So for those of you who
just showed up,
this is how we roll.
OK, we got a sign, we
got meters, we got
lights, we got radar?
OK, on your marks.
Geek Dad, you ready?
OK.
I Fix It, pay attention.
Ready?
On your mark, get set, ride!
And they're coming
out of the gate!
Geek Dad, always fresh out of
the gate, never having a
problem with that.
I Fix It, falling down.
Geek Dad, navigating
everything.
Unbelievable.
You guys can't see, but Geek
Mom is furiously giving the
oomph to Geek Dad.
Unbelievable, coming
over the course.
You know, they have just figured
out this whole thing.
I mean, they are like the
Michael Jordan of LEGOs.
He blew out a droid,
that's two points.
You got this, it's Geek Dad.
One minute 27.
27 seconds.
He can't count.
37.
You have now broken all
of your own records.
OK, stay there.
Let's pass the holy--
final round, ladies
and gentlemen!
The moment I have been
waiting for.
GB, you got it?
Holy Grail, coming in, watch
yourself, watch yourself.
A super prize there,
very nice bot.
You know, Trevor, I just picked
up Geek Dad's bot, and
you can really feel
the girth of it.
I'll give you a moment
to check your stuff.
Pump your tires,
check your oil.
Is your RAM OK?
Battery power?
You want to get out of here?
OK, this is it.
Ladies and gentlemen, we have
spent 12 hours trying to get
to this place.
So it comes down to these two.
All the way across the
pond, Team GB, aka
the Green Bay Packers.
Sorry, Great Britain,
just for a joke.
And all the way from
the internet, Geek
Dad and Geek Mom.
Are you guys ready?
OK, this is it, folks, you're
not going to get to watch
another race after this, except
for the loser round.
On your marks, get set, Droid!
[HUMMING RACING TUNE]
All right, the Sherman Tank
against the Green Goblin!
Geek Dad, navigating the way,
steady but always on!
Geek Dad, over the
mountain, going
through the green mountain.
GB's taking [INAUDIBLE] tough
one, slowly but surely!
Geek Dad, battling it
out, [INAUDIBLE].
The pressure is on, he's
looking tough.
GB, back to his own, the
full monty, he does the
[INAUDIBLE].
Oh, but it doesn't matter,
you've got to get over this.
Come on, Geek Dad, we know
you can do this.
You've done it a
million times.
You've done it three if
you've done it twice.
Here it comes, but he still
has to navigate through.
You've done this check--
Geek Dad, you got it.
There we go.
All right, presses on, get out
of the way, plowing through.
USA!
Unbelievable.
Geek Dad, coming from behind.
Can you believe the suspense?
Oh, there we go.
Geek Dad, you [INAUDIBLE].
Take your time, be patient.
No!
Unbelievable!
All the way from the
pond, it's still
trying to move around.
Nantesters.
OK, so post-analysis,
cut to Trevor.
Holy cow, I had no idea that
Great Britain would
pull that one out?
TREVOR JOHNS: Wow.
You know, very, very different
design philosophies
from both of robots.
You had Geek Dad and Geek Mom,
which built a very large,
heavy robot with
a lot of speed.
And on top of that,
they combined
it with great traction.
They will clear right over that
first obstacle, over the
mice, and make a straight
line across.
If they hadn't gotten stuck, I
think they had a great chance
of winning.
On the other hand, the other
robot just kept going.
You could not stop it.
You flip that robot, it
was on its side, and
it just kept driving.
So really just a testament
to the
perseverance of that design.
I think either of these guys
could have won, it was just
bad luck that Geek Dad and Geek
Mom got stuck on that
second obstacle there
on the ramp.
All right, back to you, Tyler.
TYLER HANSON: Unbelievable.
I am completely blown away by
what has happened here.
We are now onto our way where
we're going to give away our
actual style award.
Ladies and gentlemen,
[INAUDIBLE]?
Where's my Pelagonians?
Nice job.
We still have two more awards
to give away, OK?
All right, everybody here can
help me out here, because what
we're going to do is give a show
of hands, show of hands
for actually who's going to win
this little style award.
Now who am I missing?
I got Nantes.
Where's my other guys?
Where's Curious Creatures?
Curious Creatures?
And then we're missing
one more.
Pelagonians, where's
my Santa Barbara?
Santa Barbara, Santa Barbara?
Ah, that's WALL-E.
He's hiding.
Santa Barbara, where
are you at?
Yes, WALL-E, come on in.
OK, there we go.
You guys could still
win for style.
All right, put it
down Nice there.
Very proper.
Look at this beautiful
collection of industrial
design and manufacturing
in America.
Who says we don't make anything
anymore in America?
Proof.
We're going to only take one.
OK, hold tight.
I want you guys to vote with
your minds, though, OK?
That's a good shout out.
OK, I'm going to start here.
OK you are my voting board,
everybody here.
If you're drinking and not
paying attention to me, I want
you to go into the bar, OK?
I'll throw you out of here.
This is serious business.
For style, you guys
are going to rate.
I'm going to call out, and I
want you just to raise your
hand, I'm going to
take a show.
For WALL-E--
no whoo-ees, no whoo-whoos.
OK, a few handfuls not bad.
For Team Curious Creatures,
what do we got?
Anybody else?
No?
OK, for this guy?
Unbelievable.
I'm going to give it all the
way to France, Nantes.
And you guys were here the
first, so thanks for coming
and playing.
You win.
Winning style.
For those of you who don't know,
they couldn't make it
out of the starting gate.
So style does not equal
functionality.
Oh man, but it looks good.
OK, go ahead and
pull this guy.
Santa Barbara, I'm
so proud of you.
Go ahead and take
your bot back.
You've got to take it.
There you go.
Nantes, go ahead and take it.
Clear the runway.
Ladies and gentlemen, not only
was this one stylish, but it
also gets the award for being
the most technically advanced
in the LEGO competition.
Technically, it didn't really
work, so I don't think they
should get anything technical.
Now, we have one more
race to do.
We have these two guys, who
are the [INAUDIBLE].
So we're going to come down to
the number two winner, which
I'm going to put a lot
of money on Geek Dad.
OK, in case you were wondering,
we're still going.
This is it.
This is the final is that I'm
going to announce for the rest
of my life for LEGOs
this year.
OK, you guys looking good?
This is just a straight
fight to the finish.
First man across, that's
all he gets.
And go!
Coming out of the gate,
Buckeyes, looking tough,
holding strong.
Geek Dad, going over
the mountain.
That's just an illusion.
[INAUDIBLE].
OK, we'll start over.
It's all right, drag it out.
This is called beating
a dead horse.
I would like to thank all of
you for being so patient.
you for playing with little
LEGOs when you were children.
I'm getting very--
that's unbelievable.
Geek Dad's coming on, though.
Look out!
That's called a do over.
You still have time, you
still have time.
You drive like you're
from Ohio.
Did we lose the Droid?
Come on, Geek Dad.
There we go.
You're home free.
The Droid died.
There we are, you're
back on it.
You still have time.
The suspense is killing me.
This is unbelievable.
Never in the history of LEGO bot
racing have we had a race
quite like this.
Geek Dad, I think you've got to
parallel park that thing.
Come on, get in there.
Yeah!
That's a victory lap.
Ladies and gentlemen, I am so
proud of all of you for
watching grown adults watch
grown adults play with LEGOs
at South by Southwest. We're
coming to do all they way from
the Google Developer House here
in Googlelandia at the
Google Village.
I'd like to thank LEGO.
Thanks, LEGO.
I'd like to thank Google.
Thanks, Google.
I'd like to thank all of you
for drinking and watching
people play with LEGOs.
Do I need anything else?
Oh, NewTek!
NewTek, for doing all
this streaming.
Thank you guys for making
me look good.
My name is Tyler Hanson, I don't
care if you care about
that, but that's what I do.
Give it up for everybody.
You're done!
It's over!
[APPLAUSE AND CHEERING]
MALE SPEAKER: We're here in
Austin, Texas, where teams
have gathered from all over the
world to test their skills
at conquering a custom built
obstacle courses using nothing
but a LEGO Mindstorms
kid and an
Android-powered phone or tablet.
Live from the Google Developers'
House at South by
Southwest, this is
Google Developers
LEGO Mindstorms Rumble.